[Applause]  got to get it in  it'll come into valentine's back to  ingram for the win  yes  three tenths of a second to play you  said you saw it from here  now you gotta  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  angle  for this shot  joel myers the moment that that ball  left his hand you knew that it was good  you felt good  yes i have my hand up i have my hand in  the air if you see me in the background  my hand is in the air i knew it bingo  and okogie hesitated just a moment  because you don't want to fat the last  thing you want to do with foul  bang  let's go home  brandon ingram by the way with the game  winner 33 points he was only six or  seven for me on the ark tonight  that is unbelievable i love it i love it  this is what stars do  this is what stars do and he's back in  his game his rhythm  tell him josh tell them josh  brandon  yeah this group needed